the president is in town right now he's
in he's here you know that okay just try
and settle down this guy in the front
row just went yep
that's it the President of the United
States is here and he's just a yeah
maybe that's how he's responded to all
news in his life sir you have a son yeah
had to be one or the other your were you
from sir oh you're from camp that's why
he doesn't give a about the
president whatever that's your problem I
also hear the host of The Apprentice is
here too that's right he hasn't heard
the news yeah yeah no a true story today
President Trump visited Los Angeles in
an attempt to raise money for his 2020
reelection campaign he's in town raising
money that's right ladies and gentleman
he raised $48 he's not pi this is a
weird town certain people don't like him
he right here here and his home of New
York City yeah his most hated place yeah
yeah he raises more money in Canada sir
than he does yeah very well there the
governor of speaking of California the
Governor of California announced a
twenty million dollar campaign to warn
of the negative effects of vaping 20
million dollars to warn people about
vaping yeah I can't believe it cost 20
million dollars to say it makes you look
like a total douchebag that could be me
during a during a Broadway play starring
Tom Hiddleston did you hear about this
during a Broadway play starring Tom
Hiddleston a female audience member
masturbated twice twice while he was on
stage yeah
it turns out she's the theater critic
for pornhub
it'll still more like diddles tonight
I'm saying everybody no no don't applaud
that kind of behavior that's wrong what
I did well times are changing people are
evolving Merriam Webster's dictionary
has been updated to be inclusive of
people whose gender is non-binary I
think that's very good yeah yeah good
yeah yeah while I applaud the action I
don't see why they had to use my photo
[Applause]